um most I I want to emphasize that most
of what theorists do is wrong okay and
one of the main sort of in my view most
important things about a theorist is
they should be willing to recognize when
they've gone wrong
any sufficiently advanced technology is
indistinguishable from Magic
welcome everybody to an episode that is
coming to you courtesy of audience
demand as well as host demand uh and it
is with a renowned uh theoretical
physicist cosmologist uh named Neil
Turok who I've known for decades uh
since he's been so kind as is his want
to Mentor thousands maybe millions of
people around the world and as a young
grad student I met him uh when he first
came up with some of the ideas that
would later encourage experimental
cosmologists such as myself to pursue a
unique signal in the cosmic microwave
background that we'll get to called
b-mode polarization and Neil did some of
the definitive work on that he's also
collaborated with uh good friends and
Friends of the show like like Paul
steinhardt and Aegis and others and
today he is joining us all the way from
Edinburgh Scotland and that is Neil
Turok a renowned scientist His official
bio is sometimes out of date uh but it
is reading as follows per he is the
director emeritus of the perimeter
Institute for theoretical physics and
that uh he became Emeritus in 2019 he
was there much longer uh than that or I
spent many weeks visiting with him and
his colleagues and he originally
originates his personal Big Bang came in
South Africa and Johannesburg and will
maybe get to some of that how that is
early uh childhood influenced him in San
Diego and Neil you may not know this but
I have to get you here we have a huge
South African population I don't know if
you've ever been to La Jolla but it's a
it's quite astounding I have yeah and
I'm very jealous
Yes actually yeah they say Cape Town is
more similar than Johannesburg but at
any rate he is the also the uh the
holder of the inaugural hake's chair of
theoretical physics at the University of
Edinburgh and he has been there since uh
since 2020
he obtained his uh his PhD uh way back
when in 1992 was it uh uh he was a
postdoc at fermilab in Santa Barbara
he's one of the Maxwell Metal He's
written many books he's worked with uh
the only you know one of the few guests
I never got besides your fellow South
African uh Elon Musk I hope to get him
someday Neil if you can put in a good
word but uh Stephen Hawking who I barely
miss getting maybe a few years back but
um right but that's for the ages at any
rate I want to ask you first of all uh I
want to thank you so much for for
joining us and you are seriously here in
part because of my strong desire uh but
also because the audience was basically
begging for it and will take audience
questions in just a bit
okay so uh so Neil we always start off
by asking authors of phenomenal books
such as yourself along with your
co-author and past guest uh Paul
steinhardt we always ask you if you're
willing to play a game that we call
judging books by their covers
[Music]
you're never supposed to do but you
wrote uh along with Paul a phenomenal
book
uh called endless universe and in fact
that's the title of this episode and uh
I want to ask you we'll get into all
your incredible uh delightful work but
that book is a popular book and I want
to ask you what is the meaning of the
title of the book and what is the cover
meant to evoke in the minds of readers
and we'll show a cover over this so can
we please judge your book by its cover
okay
um wow the book was really trying to
convey how exciting it is to be able to
make models of the entire universe and
its entire history
um and then test those models against
Real data
um and so I'm always very clear to
differentiate between
theorists which I call imaginary people
and experimentalists who I call real
people thank you and that's a little bit
of a joke on uh complex mathematics
where you have real and imaginary
numbers
but that's really the way I see things
is that the theorist's job is is of
course to benefit from the incredible
observations which are made by people
like you
think a lot about them try to make
mathematical models which fit them and
ideally which make more predictions
which then people like you can check
um most I I want to emphasize that most
of what theorists do is wrong okay and
one of the main sort of in my view most
important things about a theorist is
they should be willing to recognize when
they've gone wrong
um put themselves up to scrutiny to test
both mathematical and
and observational and if either fail
move on to a better Theory so although
that book I was very excited at the time
we had a theory which was connecting the
big bang with string theory
and a development of string theory
called M Theory
I was excited about it but at the time
but I have to say uh the more I thought
about it the more I doubted its uh
foundations
and so although I was excited about
endless universe I've written another
book since called the universe Within
that is actually also a popular book
um which again tries to give a picture
of the what it's like to think about the
universe
but what I'm really excited about now is
almost the opposite of what's in the
endless universe
which is that the point the main point
is that observations of the universe
made by people like you
uh have revealed something incredible
which is that universe is unbelievably
simple
and by simple I mean very economical
in what it takes to describe it you just
need five numbers
um and so far there's no evidence for
anything more than those five numbers
whereas when we look at our theories
they are they have become unbelievably
complex Arcane with a million
assumptions and fixes and starting about
five years ago
um I basically
decided this has all become you know a
bit of a joke to to be honest
uh what we should be doing is being
strongly Guided by the data to
constructing much simpler models of the
universe
and by simply I don't mean uh less
precise or vager or or anything like
that
I mean that basically we the evidence is
we've been missing something
um and I'll I'll go into detail about
what that something is
and once I made this switch As I said
about five years ago I said look I'm
just not willing to build these Arcane
models anymore I'm going to be
ruthlessly self-critical meaning that
I'm not willing to introduce even one
extra field into the standard model
standard model is basically a well well
verified picture of what we know about
physics I'm not gonna I'm gonna be
extremely reluctant even to introduce
one
new ingredient
by that assumption I'm just reeling out
all the models that have been developed
in the 40 in the last 40 years
everybody's been introducing extra
Fields extra particles extra dimensions
you know and what did we end up with we
ended up with the Multiverse
which is the least predictive Theory
ever
okay and uh most predictive well it
predicts yeah it predicts the most but
it's it's the the least testable let's
say
where is the evidence both on the very
large scale and on the very small scale
has gone in the opposite direction so
the Large Hadron Collider you know the
greatest experiment ever built
discovered the Higgs boson
and absolutely nothing else okay so most
theorists like me 99 of theorists are
extremely disappointed at that result oh
my God everything we've done for the
last 40 years has led to nothing there's
just no extra particle to be found
and uh I'm exactly the opposite what my
interpretation is that nature is has
been smarter than we have been
and nature figured out how to get away
with just having the bare minimum you
know the Higgs boson which is necessary
to make uh standard physics work and no
more
so on the tiniest scale we have this
surprising economy in the laws of
physics
on the larger scale it's the same thing
the Planck satellite uh subsequent
experiments your
forthcoming very exciting experiment
with the Simon's Observatory you know so
far these have revealed nothing new
uh that's not bad that's that's a huge
challenge for fundamental physics it
says to us maybe we're working on on you
know a questionable set of assumptions
maybe there are principles
very economical very powerful principles
which we haven't yet figured out which
will resolve the paradoxes we have
such as the dark matter the dark energy
the Big Bang itself uh what goes on in
black holes you know that they're very
very basic paradoxes and maybe we just
need to think a little harder
um so after I've started following this
line of research about five years ago
it's very difficult because you've
essentially tied your hands together I'm
not allowed to introduce a new particle
okay and but we've made amazing progress
at least I find it amazing we've
realized what the dark matter is it's
probably a right-handed neutrino which
is already there in the standard model
it's extremely economical explanation
we've found
this is something I'm most excited about
recently a new explanation for why the
universe is so simple on large scales
you know the the geometry of the
universe what is the universe like on
large scale well in first approximation
it's flat space it's the thing you learn
about in geometry in Primary School
you know there's X Y and Z there's no
curve at curvature at all why is it the
simplest possible geometry it's a huge
puzzle which motivated the theory of
inflation so now we have a new
explanation
and the explanation is extremely
economical
it it doesn't make it easy to understand
but it basically develops Stephen
Hawking's ideas about black holes
and we
we literally do a calculation of the
thermodynamics of the universe
which
I'll say
very briefly
shows that you know just like the gas in
a room
um
will distribute itself evenly in space
because that is the most probable
configuration of the atoms if you Chuck
them in with some energy allow them to
randomize they will spread themselves
out uniformly in a smooth distribution
you don't have to introduce somebody to
smooth that or do something active
another field or particle it just does
it itself that's thermodynamics
and so we figured out the thermodynamics
of the cosmos
using Hawking's insights and with no
finay going
um with new particles or whatever with
some very simple mathematical
assumptions we find the most probable
universe is flat uh exactly the geometry
we see and it's the simplest geometry
and so
that's an entirely new explanation it
doesn't require any new ingredients it
will take people a long time to accept
this well aware of that because people
have built their careers for 40 years on
differing different assumptions but I'm
personally very excited about it I think
what we're seeing is a way through
to explain all the puzzles all the major
puzzles in theoretical physics
with absolutely minimal additions to
what we already know
well there was a man who was an alumna
alumnus of uh Irfan University who had
uh had a fair a bit of experience with
simplification with unification and uh
with really constructing a strict
mathematical model of the universe and
uh it worked pretty well uh except for
the fact that it was also based on very
simple principles involving gears and
vortices and whirlpools and of course
we're speaking about the late great uh
James Clerk Maxwell who's a talent in
all of it and maybe you know in the
spirit of of a Higgs or a Yang Mills or
uh in the same in the same way what do
you make of his ultimate what he did
Neil is so interesting because he was
absolutely correct for all the wrong
reasons and we see that again and again
in science you see that with Galileo he
was right about Universal gravity or
Newton was around about universal
gravitation completely wrong about how
it propagated Galileo was completely
right about the the orbit of the Earth
around the Sun thought it was
responsible for the tides that had
nothing to do with the times
um but tell me Neil is it possible
sometimes that brilliant theorists can
have the right idea for the wrong reason
and in that way give us a glimpse of
Truth and maybe could that be happening
with inflation in the Multiverse just to
be a little bit of a steel man and yeah
yeah no it's a good question and it's a
big puzzle why
inflation and the Multiverse have become
so popular
because objectively this is a theory
with uh an infinite variety of models of
lots of parameters lots of Freedom
extremely hard to prove wrong
um so on the face of it
uh it's a theory which isn't
particularly scientific
traditionally it would be regarded as
unfalsifiable and therefore not part of
science
but um what happened is the field of
theoretical physics has kind of been
pushed into a corner
where many of The Luminaries I mean very
uh great theorists like Stephen Weinberg
um who you know was more or less a
founder of our modern picture of of uh
physics and the standard model
um came around to this point of view of
the Multiverse and inflation
and I've I always found it sort of
surprising uh that they did but they did
for for for
you know what you could say were good
reasons I mean there's a certain logic
behind the steps people followed but
it's just a case of you know when you
when when you make a few one false term
and there's no uh kind of experimental
check
or insufficient experimental checks you
can very easily go wrong and so I think
I think that's what's happened I think
in fact around the time I entered
theoretical physics you know
um in the 1980s
um the uh that's when the field went
wrong okay I'm not saying it was my
fault yeah
Stephen had something to do with it I
think Stephen Hawking had a little bit
to do with it he actually in in A Brief
History of Time which I went back and
read yeah after his death he didn't
think it's a big deal about not only is
uh is is there no boundary is there no
beginning but but that you know the CMB
basically proves that there is an
inflation there is a Multiverse and uh
and he really went quite quite uh and
he's so influential uh although my first
guess my first ever guest on the podcast
uh was Freeman Dyson uh who I loved and
uh was incredibly influential I'm sure
you knew him when you were a professor
at Princeton as well yeah many
interactions with he he said the safest
thing in life to do Neil is to make a
bet with Stephen Hawking because either
he was wrong uh AB initio or he would
eventually switch positions so you'd win
no matter what but I think in this case
he he really did and then he went even
deeper in his final book uh with Leonard
Milan now who was a guest on the show
and he said M Theory is basically
accepted which I even as an
experimentalist I know that's not
correct so who do you make of this
influential you know kind of these
towering figures that really suck up all
the oxygen and and kind of mandate the
direction of the field like the
weinbergs like the you know nowadays
there's many of them many young ones and
I don't want to criticize any of them
but there are very few working on what I
would say are the flaws right often I
hear I hear this Neil I hear well
inflation's not a theory and the
Multiverse isn't a theory it's a
consequence of a paradigm and I'm like
well where do we go to hear about you
know like um
these are excuses is honestly they're
just excuses and it takes some courage
um to say that out loud yeah I could
really only do it because I was you know
academically secure I had a position in
fact the reason I really came to my view
that the field has gone wrong is that I
was director of perimeter Institute
which was the fastest growing best
supported Institute dedicated to
theoretical physics in the world and so
my responsibility was to hire young
people who were actually going to make
discoveries you know and I was committed
to doing that
and so I had to look very carefully at
all the different fields of theoretical
physics and weigh up the real prospects
of progress
and during that it put me in a very
unique position where I I sort of had to
have an overview of the whole field and
based on that
um had to be objective because you know
we we were
essentially investing
you know in a place where which had
opportunities to invest like no other
um
and so what I decided is that um going
with this going with the flow
was absolutely not the way forward
um and so I made that decision in my
capacity as director I also made it
personally in my own research and
because I had the freedom with my own
research to go down whatever path I I
wanted
this really made me rethink everything
um so now you asked about Maxwell
Maxwell is an amazing example uh what
happened historically was you know he
was a product of his environment uh
Edinburgh and and Scotland at that point
it was it was the age of Scottish
Enlightenment in the 18th century and
they questioned everything they
questioned you know Big Brother in
England
uh England had two universities Oxford
and Cambridge and Scotland had three
okay
and the Scottish ones had a totally
different philosophy which was Public
Access
so no matter which background you came
from
bright kids were very strongly
encouraged to go to university
and so in this environment people are
essentially the mentors of Maxwell were
trained and uh you know blossomed so
people like David Hume Adam Smith in
economics these people rethought
everything from scratch okay and so that
was the culture Maxwell was was raised
in
and being very bright he then went to
Cambridge uh I mean he went to Cambridge
after he made his discovery about light
and electromagnetism
um
but uh he he was absolutely unafraid to
challenge the Orthodoxy and you're quite
right to say that his way of picturing
the world turned out not to be you know
what we use now we take the mathematics
much more seriously than we take the
machines that he used to build the
mathematics but but that doesn't matter
at all I mean the equations are valid
and I would say Maxwell's equations are
actually guiding us to what happened at
the Big Bang
because they guided Einstein to his
theory of gravity Einstein said that
he's basically developing a version a
theory
for Gravity modeled on Maxwell's theory
of electromagnetism
uh Maxwell's equations tell you about
relativity the speed of light ultimately
told you about photons and quantum
mechanics and so you know Maxwell is
sort of the inspiration for modern
theoretical physics
and part of my reason in fact of coming
to Edinburgh is I feel it's a place with
this amazing history of sort of
breakthrough thinkers
and it's not too high bound okay
having spent time in Princeton in
Cambridge you know dot dot dot
um I I wanted to come somewhere where I
felt there was an openness
um to rethinking the foundations because
that is what I think is needed yeah if I
could show a slide I'll illustrate this
let's do that let me uh cue you up okay
yeah you should have your screen sharing
permissions there you go all right so
let me just show you can you see my
screen yeah I see it uh you want to push
perfect yeah perfect
right so this is all of physics in one
line uh it's an amazing achievement
we have gravity which is sort of Newton
and Newton's constant is here and
Einstein and the curvature of space
now describes black holes which we see
then we have Maxwell that's this term
and the photons all the forces which
keep the particles together
then we have the description of
particles due to the rack that's this
PSI quantity here and this is dirac's
formula and then we have the Higgs okay
now uh it's quite funny that the Higgs
although it's a relatively simple thing
has three terms in this equation that's
actually a minus because we we always
look for an economy and when you have uh
you know long equations it's usually a
sign you don't really know what's going
on
but anyway there are three terms
involving the Higgs these are particle
masses and these are um the electro-week
Gage boson masses originate here and
then the hex boson which uh Higgs
predicted you can think about the Higgs
boson really is the water which the
particles travel through
um and because the water makes the
provides some resistance to the
particles
um uh it it gives them mass and and
stops them moving at speed of light
so here is everything now in this
formula you'll see it's mathematical
there's E oil is number
2.718 dot dot dot that's just because
exponentials are right in the heart of
physics you know exponential growth is
what we use in the inflation describing
economic inflation for example
exponential growth of populations
in physics you get an exponential but it
ha it's of a strange number whose square
is -1
and you know non-physicists always find
this extremely worrying it's called the
imaginary number
um but this was discovered in the uh
1500s by some Italians that if you
introduce this imaginary number some
somehow you can you can solve uh an
infinite number of equations much more
easily
and um so this imagery number lies at
the heart of physics quantum physics in
in sort of physical terms you can say
that all of physics is just interference
uh these are called phases and you add
up the phases and they interfere and
that's everything
okay so here are all the laws of physics
now why do I say we have to rethink this
the reason is that we actually don't
know if this integral it's a very
beautiful thing it's saying that you
allow so if a particle goes from A to B
you actually allow it to go anywhere on
root
so it can go to the moon and come back
and then what you do is you add up all
the phases for all of the paths and they
interfere typically they interfere
destructively so the particle doesn't go
there but you have to add them all up
anyway
and that gives you the amplitude to go
from A to B and then you square it and
you get the probability so this is a
beautiful formula due to Richard Feynman
All the known laws of physics are
compatible with it yeah but a very
long-standing puzzle is whether this
formula actually makes any sense
um the reason is it's very infinite this
formula you know the number of ways of
going from A to B is infinite
and you have to very carefully deal with
that Infinity
and so actually that's a puzzle which
I've been working very hard on in the
last couple of years we think we have a
nice way of dealing with it but I have
to say that this formula although used
everywhere in quantum physics
um is uh without solid mathematical
foundations
and and so I've come to the point of
view that making sure we understand
those foundations is actually critical
so what is that though Neil is it is it
an interpretation I've I've heard things
like Einstein I mean Einstein would say
so many different things of course uh
yeah sometimes they're mutually
inconsistent I mean he would talk about
the time and then he said you know time
is is doomed as an allusion to fade away
and I've never really understood what
that meant but I guess the question for
you is is this is this a you know kind
of a tautology this equation that
basically you're using math but but
essentially you're saying it's
inconsistent we don't understand it and
it's not just because as a past guest
you know Michio Kaku says well you know
string theory is just the same as
Maxwell's equations both have an
infinite number of terms and you have to
tell me what the vacuum stand is I said
that's not my job my job is to prove you
wrong not not to prove you're right
right so what do you mean that it's
inconsistent or that it's you know is it
philosophical where are we going no no
no it's a very so if you ask if you ask
an any sort of honest theoretical
physicist how do you justify using this
formula
the first thing they will tell you
is if if they're honest and and sort of
rigorous is that you've got to get rid
of this imaginary number by rotating
time to imaginary values right as hockey
very powerful trick okay and it's
actually used and the reason you need to
do it is because it removes the
oscillations you see what what this
formula tells you is you've got to add
up all these phases the
the way physics works is these phases
interfere this is like you know two
water waves like a water wave
encountering a barrier with two slits in
and the water wave continues through the
slits and then these waves interfere and
you get basically beautiful pattern what
we call interference pattern and uh but
you've got to
keep track of these phases properly and
that's very difficult so usually people
just remove them by changing time making
time imaginary and I Stephen you know
taught me this method uh I used it to
study gravity and we discovered it fails
it fails miserably but in this book Neil
of course he says he says I'm going to
introduce it it's just a trick and uh we
shouldn't take it seriously and then
later on he bases the no boundary you
know a Hawking heart yes on this trick
so what is it is
it is a trick it is a trick and Hawking
to his credit was always looking for the
very simplest way to explain anything
and here's no boundary proposal is an
extremely beautiful idea it basically
says why is the universe is the way it
is today well we don't Prejudice that in
any way by assuming anything about the
beginning we allow it to do whatever it
likes to do
um in the past
and is no boundary proposal was that
there was no boundary
uh in the quote beginning of the
universe so you you sum over geometries
which are smooth
uh and sort of round off nicely in the
past the virtue of it was that it was
mathematically precise and principled
and very appealing very economical
the problem was that when you calculate
it in detail as we did
um this would be three or four years ago
we found it as mathematically
inconsistent
so now Hawking to his great credit was
open to the criticism they invited me to
a uh a private retreat
I went with a whole bunch of
with him and a whole bunch of his
collaborators we discussed it in detail
and I wouldn't say I can't say Hawking
accepted it but he didn't argue against
it
and then when his collaborator
um sorry you just mentioned his name he
the internal no the one who wrote the
popular books with him oh Leonard
Millard now yeah Leonard not not enough
when he he's written a recent book yes
about
um basically what it was like to work
with Hawking yeah and in that book he
explains how he asked Hawking what do
you say about Neil's work
because it directly contradicts your no
boundary proposal and and Neil is
claiming it's wrong and Hawking was
unbelievably generous
Hawking said
when you're a theorist most of the time
you're wrong
and when somebody shows that points out
a floor
in your assumptions you have to be
grateful because what they're doing is
actually saving you time you don't want
to waste your time on a thing that's
wrong I mean if you read the quote in
not enough's book about
our work on no boundary you have to come
away saying Hawking was amazingly
scientific and generous generous
gracious you know gracious so
um what I'm do the way I would describe
what I'm doing now is try trying to
implement Hawking's idea
because I think it's the most beautiful
idea for the beginning of the universe
whatever that means I'm trying to
implement it in a way which is
consistent
and if I have time I'll show you some
pictures of how we think it it yeah
let's go there now because you you have
the screen okay yeah so so main picture
for main uh take home from this slide I
mean it looks like a horrible
mathematical equation but
it's describing everything all the laws
of physics in one formula as I say the
our task is there is really to make sure
this equation is Meaningful
um and uh
uh and and that's what I'm I'm focused
on I should say my uh listeners so about
half the audience you have a hundred
thousand people in the uh into the
impossible family about half of them are
probably uh listening on audio only so
please make sure to visit Dr Brian King
to see the slides but also uh look up a
video by Neil Tura called the
astonishing Simplicity of the of the
universe uh it has several million views
um and it is really everyone uh or you
know a renowned kind of introduction to
some of these ideas that Neil's
exploring from a few years ago when he
was first grappling with them so I want
to point that out but we'll Endeavor to
discuss these Topics in more detail now
you're showing uh Peter higgs's uh paper
I think this is his first paper uh yeah
he's also called Gage boson so yeah
let's uh let's explore this equation
thanks Brian uh yeah the lecture is
called the astonishing Simplicity of
everything yes and as you say that
that's really when I was first beginning
to explore these ideas hopefully today
I'm going to tell you a lot more detail
yeah where we've been LED now I want to
point out Peter Higgs paper this is the
entire thing right this is the paper
that won in the Nobel Prize it's one and
a half pages
and uh the funny thing is I gave a talk
at Princeton I don't want a badmouth
Princeton too much okay but you know
they they can take it yeah uh I gave a
talk at Princeton a few years ago and I
when he when this Higgs boson was just
discovered
and I was celebrating this you know
somebody comes from Left Field
with a new idea about this uh the way of
how you break symmetry
and then 50 years later right it was it
was almost 50 years to the day what they
predict you know was discovered in in
nature
in a 10 billion Euro Machine you know
it's it's just an amazing story and in
fact what won him the Nobel Prize is
this one line in the paper
this this is the Higgs boson this is its
mass
okay and uh so now here's Peter Hanks
okay he's he's still around uh I see him
regularly he's he he's quite ancient and
housebound now but very gracious uh
individual
uh here he is in the biggest experiment
ever conducted the Large Hadron Collider
and he looks like he knows what's
happening and I can assure you you he
has absolutely no idea how this thing
works we only let theorists into the
experiment for publicity shots Neil you
know that exactly exactly so and that
doesn't matter at all you know his job
is to think through
uh you know what makes sense
and and that sounds easier than it is
it's a tough job because these things
which are going on are extremely remote
from any of us you know very hard for us
to picture in our minds and we have to
use mathematics as a guide because it's
our only sure way of checking that the
logic is correct and uh and that's what
he did you mentioned Princeton and I'm
waiting for the for the uh you know for
the the claws to come out but uh yeah
right close it was passed guest first
guest on the podcast Freeman Dyson who
Peter to come to the institute for
advanced study in the summer when he was
unsabbatical after this paper that
really gave him the courage so I'm
curious to hear what was the what's the
essence of the of the gentle kind of uh
uh we ought to have a little bit of
spice on the podcast yeah two things so
actually when Peter was a young lecturer
in Edinburgh
he had a PhD student
who got an offer from uh North Carolina
at Chapel Hill to go for a postdoc
and at that time Bryce DeWitt was the
head and it was a famous place you know
Nuclear Physics lab
um one of the most prominent places
Bryce
exactly huge Guru at the time so the
student decided to leave physics
and so Peter wrote to Bryce DeWitt and
said can I come instead
so he went to Chapel Hill as a postdoc
he offered he a very shy person by the
way Peter Higgs very shy very modest
went to Bryce DeWitt and said could I
give a seminar about this idea about
symmetry breaking and Bryce DeWitt said
well explain it to me first and so he
did and Bryce DeWitt who was like the
world expert on Quantum field Theory and
everything related to this
said no it's nonsense
um you can't give a seminar you'd be
wasting our time so and so Peter never
gave a seminar there and then as you say
um Freeman Dyson uh uh invited Peter to
Princeton and and uh and then the rest
is history
but um
but I the reason I mentioned Princeton
is actually I showed this slide and to
my great surprise at the end of my
seminar a number of the prominent gurus
in the field who were there came up to
me and said oh you give him too much
credit you're giving him too much credit
well uh what he did we now see is kind
of trivial and Goldstone was there first
and you know yeah they had a whole
number of arguments but basically it was
uh you know so which I was just shocked
at
because
um to not recognize that a stiff to to
refuse to recognize that in
extraordinarily simple idea which
everyone else had missed by the way
suddenly
brought things into consistency
you know and and and and to be grudging
about that I just found extraordinary
but uh but but anyway that that's their
choice and Princeton is now the hub for
string theory the Multiverse uh you know
all super symmetry all kinds of
complicated ideas which so far have no
experimental evidence at all and so it's
quite clear who won that particular
debate uh you know the Higgs boson was
found nothing else what has been found
none of these other theoretical
constructions have been found
now I I sound a bit like a curmudgeon
but I'm not no I know
um here's the wonderful story 50 years
and 10 billion euros later they built
the biggest experiment uh of all time
and they found the Higgs boson and
there's Peter Higgs uh chatting to the
other Nobel Prize One winner Francois
angler also an extremely unusual and
creative uh personality
so I think what I wanted to just before
we go to the next episode I assume is
going to be on cosmology you know back
in the 80s and 90s when I started grad
school in the 90s and met you for the
first time as a Dapper young Professor I
remember uh you visiting
um uh Brown University at one point and
then we visited you in Toronto uh but
the um but back then there was a
pejorative uh coined first by uh Alan
sandidge who called cosmology the search
for two numbers and I kind of poked and
prodded at Frank close in our interview
about Peter Higgs I said isn't the LHC
worse because it's a search for one
number right it's done since and then
it's oh there's hints of new physics and
oh we have believe me Neil you
romanticize experimentalists a little
too much because you you think that
we're all just no these guys are now
talking about building a collider on the
moon and building right the size of the
solar system and uh right that's the
question that I have for you before we
turn to cosmology which is another area
of redoubt and expertise that you
uniquely have in the world uh and that
is you know are we kind of in an
ambiguity the human brain hates
ambiguity they hate we love to make
decisions pro-life pro-choice we love no
guns guns at least here in America I I
don't know
brexit or how about this brexit or no
brexit uh that'll that'll get you uh
agitated I'm sure but at the at the
heart we we kind of fixate on targets
and then when there is no Target now
we're in this desert between in
cosmology where inflation you would
freely admit and I know that you would
that inflation could be right I mean it
could be
um sure but it could be it could be true
but we'll never be able to detect it
because the energy right are going to
produce negligible demotes now when
we're in the state with particle physics
and cosmology then other things like
string theory M Theory
um uh supersymmetry all these things
will Bloom but is it ultimately hopeless
list without a tool an instrument to
right what can the Mind by itself the
Duncan experiment that Einstein Pioneer
you know thought about someone how much
can we really do without experiment and
without hope of building a a 10 to the
16th you know gev collider to replicate
the primordial Universe are we doomed
no no far from it uh I believe that we
need
um new insights into very fundamental
questions so let's go to one question so
it says this is slightly technical it is
a technical field I apologize for that
the audience is very technical too I
mean we've had 13 12 Nobel Prize winners
on so far so they're very technical good
so um I've emphasized we have to make
sense of this formula yes now the way we
use this formula in physics so far
is very very uh restricted okay so we
use certain aspects of it which work
unbelievably well
one aspect is to calculate what are
called scattering amplitudes how
particles scatter off each other and
those things are measured in
Laboratories like the Large Hadron
Collider
now most of those in fact all of those
calculations almost all of those
calculations are done
um
using what we call perturbation Theory
okay now perturbation Theory says if
some parameter is small in your formula
then you can hope to calculate it by an
expansion a mathematical expansion in
that parameter okay so uh scattering
amplitudes most of what we know about
them is perturbative
and and so this formula has only ever
been checked as an ex now the small
parameter may be really small like the
fine structure constant which is 1 over
137 that's a fairly small number and if
you calculate you know to whatever uh
fifth order in in one over a hundred you
know then you're going to get
um 10 to the minus 10 as the correction
and uh and you you may be happy with
that
so physicists have become used to sort
of only uh using this formula in
perturbation Theory what you discover in
perturbation Theory so it's a you know
basically this is a poor man's approach
you know the the rich man's approach to
this formula would be to say I want the
answer okay don't give me some
approximation to it I want to know this
formula actually makes sense as it is
for for all quantities whether I
calculate them perturbatively
non-perturbatively
Etc we don't know if this formula makes
sense non-perturbatively in fact for
Gravity nobody has even tried this
rotation to euclidean time definitely
does not make sense but that's not what
this formula says either this formula
says do it in real time calculate the
interference of different space times
uh all at once you know it's it's very
ambitious but that's what the formula
tells you you have to do and we haven't
been able to do that now the reason
people went for string theory is that in
perturbation Theory
it's very hard to get rid of the
Infinities in gravity without adding
extra ingredients like extra dimensions
of space and more particles like
supersymmetry
but that's only perturbation Theory
there's a physical mechanism which may
of itself get rid of all those
Infinities and that is that when you
when you consider very high energy
processes which is where these
Infinities come from
Gravity makes them into black holes
that's what gravity does and so if you
fire two particles together with high
energy you're going to make a black hole
and so gravity itself
eats up high energy regions and then we
believe recycles them into Hawking
radiation
now that is a very natural mechanism
whereby in this formula all the
Infinities may be removed without adding
anything extra at all the problem is the
calculations which would show that are
currently too difficult to do nobody's
ever tried they they're so hard you know
to calculate what happens when I fire
two particles together include the
effect of gravities
um allow gravity to eat up the high
energy reason regions and see if that
removes the Infinities maybe it does in
fact this is more or less how String
Theory Works
um string theory is sort of toy model of
of
gravity I would say so we don't know
that we have to add all this extra junk
we don't know that at all that's an
assumption based on an approximation
uh of what we call perturbation Theory
so nevertheless you know the vast
majority of great physicists like
Stephen Weinberg and and and many others
accepted that we have to try out String
Theory because perturbation Theory and
string theory looks better than
perturbation theory in plain old
Einstein gravity
so there are ways to resolve the
Infinities without adding extra stuff
and that's what I find much more
interesting currently is does nature do
these laws suffice to describe nature as
I said we don't actually know that they
don't and the only way we'll decide that
is by developing our capability to
calculate exactly what this formula
um
means and and yeah so I'm busy just
trying to take this formula more
seriously and see if maybe it resolves
all of these problems without any need
for extra Dimensions or strings or or
other particles or anything now before I
rudely interrupted you uh you're about
oh please go ahead you're showing
something from the great Bard and it is
not as uh the actors would say that from
the Scottish play oh that's right would
you like to uh show the Cosmetics yeah
so on the very smaller scale we've
discovered that nature is more
economical than 99 of theorists expected
right the LHC has come up with a blank
um
still worth every penny I would say uh
knowing there's nothing in my view
is in a way more inspiring than finding
a particle because it forces you back to
the drawing board that's always a good
thing you have to figure out how the
hell does nature work
if it doesn't use all these tricks and
and model you know models which we
invented to make it work how does it
work those paradoxes which motivated
strings and and super Symmetry and all
the other additions the paradoxes are
still there
how that how it might work is that
nature is more subtle and we have to
understand that formula the first
Formula uh you know more
um in more depth than we currently do
so now that's on small scales on large
scales the same story uh uh this is the
picture I'm showing the picture of from
the playing satellite of the visible
Universe uh it's the whole sky and what
you see is the pattern of irregularities
in the OR density variations in the
early universe as it came out of the big
bang and these variations gave rise to
galaxies and stars and ultimately us
um so it's a marvelous picture with very
lucky generation to see it
um it literally is the the vast Shore
washed with the farthest sea that's uh
in Shakespeare's words uh from Romeo and
Juliet because we're seeing waves and
we're seeing the waves in the uh
distribution of matter and radiation as
it emerged from The Big Bang and it's
really like an ocean we live in the
middle of this ocean and now we can see
it
um so wonderful picture
uh what is unbelievably
what is astonishing about it is how
simple it is
uh you know a priori if the universe was
built out of Lego as you went to larger
and larger scales it would get more and
more random and complicated or if it was
a Multiverse you know surely we would
expect that as we went to larger scales
it would get more complicated what we
see is the opposite
that the universe is extremely simple on
the larger scales you just need five
numbers to describe everything we see so
far and there's a ton of data it's all
consistent with essentially models that
were proposed in the 1970s
um by Jim Peebles and others which
require
um you know five numbers so again most
theorists very upset oh no there's no
clue from the data
um there's no new physics I'm the
opposite I say wow the universe is
unbelievably simple what we need is a
principle to explain how it how nature
got away with being so simple
so the five numbers I won't go through
them in detail three are for the
different kinds of energy in the
universe the baryons like us the the
neutrons and protons we're made of
um and then uh the dark matter
and as I'll explain
based on this philosophy of economy we
have a new explanation for the dark
matter which is now going to be testable
within the next uh five to ten years
and what I'm going to convey is this was
staring Us in the face since the 70s
there has been an obvious candidate for
the dark matter but due to theoretical
preconceptions we sort of refuse to see
it
so I'll explain that in a moment
the huge thing is the dark energy what
is this so most of the energy in the
universe 70 of it is in this form of
this weird energy which is absolutely
uniform in space
uh the same with time it doesn't change
in time it's constant despite people
searching for variations it seems to be
absolutely constant in time
and um it is the simplest form of energy
you could imagine in fact that's why
Einstein did imagine it in 1917 he
thought you know he wrote down these
equations for gravity and then he said
well let me try and make a universe so
I'll throw in some some form of matter
or energy uh he showed energy and matter
or equivalent so he threw in a form of
energy which is the simplest possible
form and that is what dark energy is
so he made a model cosmology it wasn't
correct but now
uh it turns out that the dark energy
introduced is there and it's the most
important energy in the universe so you
know talk about uh
uh seeing things in advance
um you know when your blunders are noble
yeah it's pretty great you know it was
no blunder it was the simplistic
assumption what we learned from this is
that
um
nature does
in many cases
use the simplest available option and in
the case of dark you know the simplest
Universe full stop would be one which
only contained dark energy and that's
what Einstein imagined so he was close
he was he was 70 70 right oh yeah and he
uh and it's too bad because he could
have had a good career Neil if he hadn't
made that point he would he would go
down in history but I want to just
gently push back the respect and love
that you know I have for you but uh but
recently I did a video on my Channel
about some work that you and and Nathan
Boyle had done on a so-called
anti-universe
travel backwards of time and I had on
one of the experimentalist um Abby vereg
professor in Chicago old friend of mine
she's young but we've known each other
for a long time and uh about the Anita
experiment in Antarctica
um yeah how how does a how does a how
does an anti-universe uh simplify things
uh let's go right there there's the
paper yeah so in a video above well I'll
sort of Link right I did about your
wonderful work with Nathan but but still
it's it's it's bemusing but but how is
it simpler right so uh as I said I've
been following the same philosophy that
you know maybe the answers are really
staring Us in the face
but we've got to you know we've got to
see them and understand them and that's
where this idea of a a universe
which which where the big bang is
preceded by an anti-universe actually
came from so how did we how did we get
to that crazy idea okay and actually
this crazy idea underlies
uh a lot of recent progress not all of
which is written up but part of which is
going to be if it works an explanation
for those density variations
which we now see
an explanation in which we predict the
amplitude
from first principles okay that's our
goal I told you we're not allowed to
introduce any new particles we we want
to try to explain the university as it
is on the basis of the laws we already
know
and what's in Prospect and that's why
I'm very busy this summer it's a hard
and complicated calculation
if it works we will explain that the
density variations in the sky they're
about one part in ten thousand
and the reason for that is that's the
square of the fine structure constant
okay I've mentioned one over 137 if you
square it you get 10 to the minus 4.
um roughly speaking that's how our uh
new picture of the universe works
and the origin of that number is
something extremely extremely
fundamental which is that when you
couple the matter in the standard model
to gravity
there's something weird called the trace
anomaly okay sounds very technical
what it means is that a symmetry of the
matter gets broken due to the curvature
of space-time
and this is called a trace anomaly
um and what goes along with it
is that you know when when you have all
this these Quantum fields which are
describing the matter so photons
electrons all of them are associated
with a Quantum field the field is
unable to stand still the vacuum so the
vacuum is not empty the vacuum consists
of all the vibrations of all the fields
that you add in the standard model
and the problem is those vacuum
vibrations gravitate
gravity detects their energy
and so for uh it must be nearly 100
years now physicists have essentially
been cheating
taken that vacuum energy of all the
fields that we know about and we've just
subtracted it okay but that is not
really consistent that is not consistent
and if you ask somebody in their bones I
mean Feynman acknowledge this
um you know all the great physicists
acknowledge this that what we do is
essentially when we do Quantum field
Theory and couple it to gravity is
essentially to cheat
so we've found a way around that cheat
we've found a way to cancel
the trace anomaly and to cancel the
vacuum energy without adding even one
particle to the standard model so that's
very exciting
and that mechanism turns out to give
fluctuations as a side effect
and those fluctuations May match the
observations we see so that would be the
best of all possible worlds if it does
work out as I hope I think all rival
theories will just fall by the wayside
uh because we'll be able to actually
calculate from the a theory we know
makes sense
what the fluctuations were at the Big
Bang so of course that's extremely
ambitious it'll probably fail
but uh that's what I'm after I'm after
an absolutely minimal and compelling
explanation for what we see
if we don't find one fine we might
decide you know either we weren't smart
enough or there isn't if there isn't one
but uh I don't see any way of resolving
that apart from trying do you think you
could get information about this not
from the particulate content of the
universe but from the electromagnetic
sector in other words we're looking for
what we call turn Simons or Cosmic
birefringine signals that would be
indicative of CP violation not
necessarily CPP but if you know if you
could ask God you know one question or
Mother Nature
I feel like I would ask about you know
are the laws of the universe Lorenzen
variant you know because we assume that
they are but right could that be the
most you know kind of preposterous
assumption and we only have access to
energy scales on Earth where I guess the
photons obey you know uh parity uh
inversions right
uh but time is another matter and and so
I wonder could we use the laboratory
that these CMB photons which have
provided so much richness in my life and
made me a wealthy they haven't made me
that wealthy but but the point being
it's my it's my uh industry right so
intellectually intellectually like
myself so is that a more promising than
looking for you know neutrinos or are
you trying to solve you know they're
they're they're both extremely promising
um let me just say a little more because
you you you about why we came up with
this crazy antiverse idea uh you know
that before the Big Bang there was a an
image of our universe so that actually
is motivated by something we know very
well in electromagnetism
which is that which is a mirror
if you when you look at a mirror you see
yourself right but you're inverted
uh left is right and right is left so
you look a little bit different in the
mirror than if somebody else sees you
but
um when you try to understand a mirror
you know there are two ways to do it
either you deal in detail with the way
the light interacts with the material of
the mirror and the way we say it is you
impose boundary conditions on Maxwell's
equations which which essentially tell
you that the electric field has to
vanish and the magnetic field is allowed
to oscillate
um on the mirror but uh a much more
beautiful way of dealing with it is to
say
put an image of yourself behind the
mirror okay where you've reflected left
to right and right to left
um and then throw the mirror away
uh then the light which travels from the
image to you
will be
exactly what you see and in physics we
call this method it sounds like a cheap
trick and it kind of is but we call it
the method of images namely instead of
solving a problem with boundary
conditions you instead
um reflect uh your side of the boundary
through the boundary to the other side
and then solve the equations as if there
were no boundary
um and so that was that was our idea a
couple of years ago that there was a pre
a pre in a sense a pre-bang
but it's a perfect mirror cop mirror
image of us
is not it's not only uh left and right
that get inverted it is time itself CPT
uh on the other side of the Big Bang
time is going appears to go in the other
direction you know the universe is
growing and galaxies are forming but in
the opposite direction of time and so on
so it's really a mirror image of us
uh you might say this is a sort of empty
notion why am I just uh sticking it
there the reason I stick this universe
there going away from us is that it
allows us to solve
if you like the boundary conditions of
what happened at the Big Bang in a very
natural way without just starting it by
hand
we are actually able to uh you know give
a consistent description of what
happened at the Big Bang
without putting putting it in my hand
namely we just mirror ourselves using
CPT which is believed to be absolutely
fundamental symmetry of nature uh no
theory has ever violated it that any no
sensible Theory consistent with Lorenzen
variants I should say has ever violated
it and uh so we make the CPT image and
then we use the regular Einstein
equations to uh to show you know to
evolve the universe from one side to the
other so it's a very very minimal
assumption and over the last couple of
years we've been thinking very carefully
is this Mirror Image Universe actually
identical to ours you know
mathematically identical you know is
there Brian Keating on the other side
interviewing
I'm left-handed I'm Sinister in that
universe
and we've come to the conclusion through
a range of sort of mathematical
arguments that indeed it is so
so the antiverse is simply a
mathematical copy of our universe it's
there for convenience for mathematical
ease of discussion it doesn't add
anything new in a sense of you know
another place where things could happen
so it's actually extremely economical
it's it's it's an absolutely minimal
theory if you like our answer to what
came before the Big Bang is uh it was us
it's just the same as us so when people
uh just just pause for one second and
talk about the interpretation by the way
I want to remind folks I'm talking with
a renowned uh uh theoretical physicist
the inaugural Higgs chair at uh
Edinburgh University uh University of
Edinburgh and that's Neil Turok who I've
known for a very long time uh and uh has
influenced cosmology me my by his
writings and his and his work and I've
done videos based on his work uh and you
should check out his uh just
phenomenally popular uh videos online
is currently uh in Scotland but before
that was the uh was the director of
perimeter Institute but um prior you
know to to getting into this we we
talked about you know uh we did talk
about matter and dark matter but there's
another form of matter anti-matter which
as I understand at Wheeler and and
Feynman at all had a notion that
antimatter could be viewed as ordinary
matter traveling backwards in time
um and and I wonder uh if you know I had
wanted to ask you what are the biggest
misconceptions that lay people have that
undergraduates have and then what your
fellow theoretical uh you know
physicists have but I don't know if
we'll have time for that but I is that
really a misconception I mean is it
really the case that we could we really
think that there is a part there is a
negative direction of time or is that
like Hawkings Wick rotations it's a
simple trick
no I don't think it's a simple trick
um I think it's an extremely deep
Insight that Feynman and Wheeler both
had and and before them
actually a guy called stukelberg whose
little known and not so popular was a
very shy person a bit like Peter Higgs
but he was the true genius uh in Quantum
field theory in the 1930s
um but apparently he wasn't recognized
and and basically went ended up going to
chemistry where people were more
receptive but he wrote papers where
there with this idea of a particle going
back a particle going backwards in time
was an anti-particle very very beautiful
idea
uh it's absolutely consistent with uh
with everything we know
um and in fact Feynman himself
made the following statement that
um and Diamond you know as as you know
won the Nobel Prize for Quantum field
Theory and was one of the most
accomplished uh practitioners Feynman
said the whole of quantum field theory
is nothing but
a clever attempt to hide the fact that
particles go backwards in time
particles can go backwards in time and
when they do their anti-particles so he
viewed you see nobody has ever seen a
Quantum field if you if anybody tells
you you know Quantum field theory is the
answer to life the universe and
everything just ask them has anyone ever
seen one uh no because the only way we
see Quantum Fields is through particles
we do observe particles in experiments
and
um and so what you've you know these
fields May somehow represent that they
do seem to represent the particles at
some level of uh accuracy very high
level of accuracy but what is actually
going on you know maybe uh maybe
particles indeed uh going backwards it
may be but you know as my brother older
brother would say you know have you ever
seen your brain I say no and he says
well how do you know uh we haven't seen
quarks either and quarks are you know
thought to be part of so what do you
would you say this would push back and
say look you know we absolutely yeah
absolutely I I I think we don't know uh
and it's true people are very suspicious
about quarks because they don't exist at
free particles but you know on the other
hand why should they uh you can imagine
particles being you know tied together
with a little piece of string uh in such
a way that you're if you try to pull
them apart all that happens is you break
the string into a new particle appears
on on each end of this free end of Frank
will check as discussed on the podcast
yeah yeah so so
um no I think the the what I would say
is that you see the why do I prefer one
image mental image over another
the first thing to say about Quantum
field theory is it's basically a
gigantic algebraic machine right that's
actually what Dyson Dyson's contribution
was to turn it into a machine it's a
calculational machine
and basically the philosophy was shut up
and calculate don't worry what's really
going on calculate the scattering Matrix
and don't worry about what actually
happened okay the kind of work I'm doing
now to understand this path integral
we don't accept that we want to know
exactly what went on during these you
know inside the path integral and people
who study quantum mechanics on its own
you know to the the foundations of
quantum mechanics and who do experiments
to understand the weirdness of quantum
mechanics increasingly they are asking
exactly that question
what is actually going on in the in the
middle
um it's called the theory of weak
measurement
you know if you may if you measure
something precisely you notoriously
collapse the wave function let's do a
concrete example the double slit
experiment walk us through that
experiment exactly so if You observe an
electron as it goes through the slits
you will destroy the interference
pattern okay so we know that a strong
measurement
uh the classic measurement in quantum
mechanics spoils your ability to see
what has happened what is actually
happening but a weak measurement this is
a very clever idea that if you couple
the quantum system to another system
and you only perform a strong
measurement on the other system and the
two systems are coupled very weakly then
you then what you can do is repeat the
quantum experiment in which you know the
coupling to the other system is so weak
it doesn't spoil that at all
non-destructible
non-destructive so the quantum system is
happily doing all its interference and
everything but then by repeating
experiment thousands or millions of
times and Performing real observations
on the weekly couple system
you can make predictions based on what
the quantum particle was doing in the
interim you know as it was going through
the two slits or as it was doing
something very quantum mechanical
and tunneling Quantum tunneling or
whatever so that's a very beautiful idea
and part of the reason I like it is it's
exactly what we have to do in cosmology
we live in the universe we're not in a
scattering Matrix we're in the middle of
the thing you know we're after the big
bang but we're we're before the end
we're coupled to it right right we're a
couple to it we're coupled very weakly I
mean whatever we measure the Hubble
constant to be does not the universe
doesn't give a damn it's much bigger
than us okay so there are all kinds of
parallels and I firmly believe that
understanding how to reconcile quantum
physics with the universe requires us
actually to understand quantum physics
in these intermediate regimes and
literally to ask you know what happens
when a Quantum particle tunnels where is
it
um how would somebody trying to measure
the particle as it is tunneling and
measure it very weakly what would they
tend to see
um so it what's fascinating to me is
that sort of these
the work on Quantum foundations which
until about 20 years ago was really
philosophy in the worst sense it was you
know going around in circles about
um rather academic points without tests
that field has changed because now we
can do experiments we can attempt to
build quantum computers uh you know
Technologies reached a point where these
sort of academic questions about what's
really going on in quantum mechanics are
becoming testable in experiment and I
think we can learn a lot from them about
how we deal with cosmology see almost
all the
Quantum physicists and I would say
without except almost without exception
all the string theorists for example who
do cosmology
do it in the following way you say given
a classical universe
namely a space-time Arena
right just given that
how do I propagate particles or Quantum
Fields or whatever on top of that Arena
and then see what happens okay now that
is not that doesn't make any sense at
all in quantum mechanics 6 you cannot
couple consistently a classical object
with a Quantum one that makes no sense
people have understood that from the
beginning of quantum mechanics either
you're all classical or your old Quantum
you can't mix the two now you know
there's some approximations in which it
looks very classical in some respects
but if you want to do it properly you've
got to quantize everything and that
means space-time itself must be Quantum
and that path integral formula I showed
you
tells you how to do that actually so
John Wheeler knew how to do it which is
that you've got to sum over all possible
space times that connect you know a
given
um the universe at one moment of time
let's say to the universe at a later
moment of time
it's a very difficult calculation not
just practically but conceptually you
know if somebody gave us the most
powerful computer of all time we still
wouldn't know how to do the calculation
because we don't know exactly how to
implement that interference formula and
that's what I'm busy trying to figure
out and I think it's possible but it
needs more mathematical insights
uh what I love about this is that the
ingredients we which go in are actually
very well established Einstein's theory
of gravity quantum mechanics this notion
of a path integral these are all kind of
very solid Notions even if they aren't
mathematically rigorous yet especially
in the path integral and so by making
them more rigorous uh I you know it's
very tough work it's very mathematical
work
but um I'm really hopeful that we will
gain insights and what I'm hoping in
particular is we'll see how to resolve
the big challenges in physics without
adding more junk okay nature is telling
us very clearly don't add junk okay
and yeah and if we add junk we are
falling into the oldest trap in science
which is when am I when the data don't
fit the model add a new parameter right
that's what everyone does in financial
mathematics economics you know you know
modeling of all sorts and people have
learned the lesson that a forecast made
using a model where you just added
something to fit the prior data you know
it very often fails uh you you the model
is only useful if
it's predictive you know and those
predictions are based on assumptions
which are minimal
um uh don't keep adding parameters and
extra stuff so we've got to stop doing
it it's an addiction it's an addiction
in the field uh the there's vast numbers
of papers which are doing that so it's
quite hard to resist this right because
what I'm doing implicitly is criticizing
all my colleagues have written tens of
thousands of papers with tens of
thousands of new particles and
parameters and I'm saying we've got to
stop okay this is not leading us to new
understanding and I'm afraid you know as
as wonderful as inflation is and I'm I'm
a big I fully acknowledge that inflation
Theory drove helped to drive
the observational efforts you know it
was what whatever inflation model was
being advocated you know was an
inspiration in the sense that you could
then try to shoot it down as an
experimentalist and and that's really
really important so I think inflation
was extremely important to the field
uh was an inspiration but doesn't need
to be correct
um what do you say to those people like
I've had on David spurgle I've had um uh
conversations with Will Kinney but his
new book on the Multiverse effectively
and they push back you know with all due
respect and they'll say well how do you
explain the large angular scale te
correlation without inflation
um how do you explain the uh the the not
quite scale invariant you know uh
spectral index how do you how do you
explain the successes of forget about
the Multiverse which Paul and I have
talked about and Aegis and I have talked
about links to those videos yeah but
let's just focus on the successes of
inflation so can you thank you thank you
yeah so so I can I can and this is our
new work so so it's a great question uh
now let me just tell you how it works
okay so
the first
the puzzle which everybody believes uh
and you know Dave circle is a good
friend and will Kinney too they have
bought the inflationary explanation okay
but
the inflationary explanation comes with
a bit of baggage you've got to assume an
extra scalar field for which there is no
observational evidence you've got to
assume that field was displaced from its
minimum and that it rolled very slowly
downhill okay so you put in the initial
conditions by hand you have to assume
all kinds of things about the quantum
state of that field and so on so it
comes with a lot of baggage
um and essentially it's a model you know
contrived to fit the data
I'm sorry Neil but it's just a again
just a for the listeners that may not be
watching we're all talking about uh uh
some technical matter now that we'll
show video on the YouTube channel but um
but in particular couldn't one say the
same thing about the Higgs it it comes
with some initial value it it is you
know the job of the theory is not to
explain you know I always say when I
took a biology class they don't start
with you know how did life form on in
the universe they start with here's DNA
here's microbiology yeah in other words
is it a problem for the theory that it
has to come up with the initial
condition like it has to instantiate
itself does it have to be it from bit as
wheeler would say I mean isn't that
asking like I mean you could say the
same thing about about no no
there's a there's a there's a huge
difference between the Higgs and
inflation
the Higgs was a mechanism to explain a
known fact the the the weak interactions
and
um so that it's not just one fact there
was an abundance of data yeah and what
Higgs did with one hypothesis
introducing a new admittedly introducing
a new particle was to explain a vast
array of data okay whereas with the with
the inflation field
you're introducing
um well essentially as I think you said
earlier inflation isn't really a theory
it's a it's a collection of models so
you're opening the door whereas the
Higgs mechanism is really quite unique I
mean it's tied down by the standard
model and its symmetries that when you
introduce this Higgs field
you're extremely constrained in how you
introduce it and essentially there's
only one free parameter and that
parameter turns into the particle mass
and and as all the other observations of
all the kind of side effects of the
Higgs mechanism as they became more and
more precise the prediction for the
Higgs particle Mass became extremely
uh narrow
and so people are very nervous oh my God
is it going to be ruled out and and you
know as late as 2012 uh people were
still worried it's going to be ruled out
that seemed to me the most likely thing
and then very last minute when that
window was finally narrowed a little
bump appeared and there it was so uh now
inflation absolutely different
you see inflation so the Higgs mechanism
is explaining a wealth of complex
processes okay uh involving particle
physics all of which are measurable in
accelerators and experiment the inflaton
and inflation is explaining one actually
two numbers
one is the amplitude of these density
variations as they come out of the Big
Bang there's roughly one part and ten
thousand that number is is being uh
explained except a number isn't
explained it's a free parameter and then
secondly what is called a slight tilt
that the fluctuations on the sky are
ever so slightly larger on large scales
than they are on small scales it's only
a one percent effect
um but
um but you know it does seem to be there
in the data so basically we've got uh
two numbers to explain
and the uh minimal inflation models
essentially introduced two parameters to
fit those two numbers they don't predict
anything but they do fit that they are
able to fit the data
the problem is they also predict
something else which are gravitational
waves which you know very well and on
that basis they are under severe
pressure now
um and so the the inflation models you
know are way less constrained
theoretically than the Higgs model ever
was
and
um so then you you're forced to say well
why do I favor one inflation model over
another
you know there's some notion of what's
simpler uh but the simpler models are
now wrong
and uh so now inflation modelers are in
the position of adjusting their model
you know with
with every new piece of data you know if
you have to adjust the model by adding a
new parameter you know you're going in
the wrong direction
so I would say inflation is you know at
best A fitting model
it because it's basically trying to fit
these two numbers
uh you know the Higgs mechanism is
fitting a Million numbers measured in
laboratory experiments and it's just
totally different much more principle
Theory and is fitting a vastly greater
array of data so that encourages me to
believe that instead of inflation there
might be a much simpler explanation a
much more principled explanation
so let me try and give you a flavor of
what I think it is and this is our res
our recent paper
which explains the flatness of the
Universe on large scales
just using thermodynamics gravity and
quantum mechanics that's all okay
so and I'll tell you how we did it yep
I'm very excited about this and I think
again you know the mathematics is
crystal clear the assumptions are
crystal clear
if it may be right or wrong because
there are assumptions but uh the
explanation is absolutely unique so
that there are still some puzzles about
it uh there always are but
um this could be
the the definitive explanation uh with
without any sort of uh bells and
whistles so let let me
explain our new explanation with an
analogy okay because it is rather
technical it's using Stephen Hawking's
work on black holes which is very famous
Stephen Hawking figured out what's
called the entropy of a black hole
and all we've done is import his method
of calculation
of entropy
yeah of gravitating systems we've taken
that calculation and applied it to the
real Cosmos okay so we have calculated
For the First Time The entropy of a
realistic Cosmos with dark energy with
radiation and with spatial curvature
and we find that provided the universe
is sufficiently big and I'll explain
what I mean by big in a moment
the most probable universe is flat
okay and the answer is crystal clear so
um if this explanation is correct
no extra theoretical ingredients are
needed right it's it stands on its own
it relies on gravity
and quantum mechanics quantum mechanics
is important in thermodynamics because
it allows you to it quantizes the states
and it allows you to count how many
states there are
and our explanation is sympathy that the
flat universe is the most probable uh if
you allow the universe to take all of
its possible States it's most likely
going to turn out to be flat so what's
the analogy
well why is the earth flat
and I'm showing here
a picture of the Earth from space made
by NASA
and what you notice when you look at
these pictures is the Earth is just this
perfectly round marble okay smooth as
anything perfectly round and smooth
and what this means is that if we I've
got a little circle showing Edinburgh if
we live in Edinburgh and if we only
travel you know uh 10 kilometers or 100
kilometers we don't need to worry about
the curvature of the Earth because
locally the universe the Earth is very
flat okay so the flatness of the Earth
is a consequence of several things one
is the Earth is very big earth is made
of about 10 to the 50 atoms okay if the
Earth was any smaller
you know and and it were round we would
see the curvature of the earth
um so the tent first of all you need to
to know that the Earth is a big object
secondly you need gravity gravity pulls
all those atoms inwards
and when it does so it makes the earth
round but you have to have dissipation
you know if a mountain collapses it
doesn't rebound
and uh you know whereas an elastic ball
will vibrate the Earth doesn't do that
you know once it falls inwards it stays
inwards
and the dissipation redistributes the
energy the potential energy let's say in
the mountain or in a ball
that energy is redistributed into heat
so uh there are vastly more ways of
arranging the Earth and a given amount
of energy
where I put all that energy and just the
the vibrations of the atoms and
molecules into heat there's so much heat
capacity in the Earth
that you know if things fall on the
earth and they make for example
a sound wave that sound wave will just
go into heat and all the energy that was
in the object as it fell will will be
redistributed into heat in the earth so
once you unders and essentially this is
entropy
that
while it may seem sort of surprising at
first sight that the most probable Earth
is round
whereas a most random Earth you know
would be very Jagged and spiky if I took
10 to the 50 atoms and treated them like
Lego I'd get a very crazy geometry but
in reality what happens is when you when
you include gravity and dissipation
then the most probable geometry for the
Earth is actually
spherical
um because it
you know we don't see it looking random
because we're not looking at the
vibrations of the molecules but all the
vibrations of the molecule is extremely
random there's a ton of entropy there
and so
um entropy favors around smooth Earth
so it's a wonderful explanation because
it doesn't require any new physics you
don't require somebody to come and
polish the Earth and make it round and
smooth you know physics does that for
you and I think Einstein said that
anytime you use thermodynamics to
explain something you know that
explanation May last forever
because uh the laws of probability are
not about to change anytime soon and if
uh you know they're just many more ways
to make around Earth than there are to
make a jagged Earth
um you know it's very likely and
whatever your laws of physics
um uh the Earth is going to be round so
um so I take inspiration by the way
there's some new evidence in favor of
this explanation involving um plankton
in the oceans which is very beautiful so
life actually had a role you know there
are mountain ranges on the earth after
all there's uh the Himalayas and the
Andes and the Rockies turns out all
these mountain ranges arose about two
billion years ago
and the reason they Rose was precisely
because the friction
of content between continental plates
was reduced about two billion years ago
you know so when two continental plates
collided instead of just sort of
grinding each other into dust and making
something smooth they slid one above the
other
uh due to the um lubrication
and the lubrication was was the carbon
in the form of graphite created by the
Plankton when life formed about two
billion years ago so the origin of life
preceded the formation of mountains
sorry just aside there's no life
elsewhere in the universe
how could you I always say to get a
solar panel you don't make a solar panel
from a solar panel you don't make a
transistor from a train you had to have
pre-existing material raw materials and
we got uh to communicate using Zoom
today because at one point we're using
whale oil to light lamps that then wrote
down equations that built Factory in
other words the the improbability of
what you just described and by the way
that Plankton only survived because the
dinosaurs were too large to notice them
and then the dinosaurs only got wiped
out because
I have to ask you just yes or no do you
think there's you know intelligent life
elsewhere in our galaxy
I don't know I don't know but I don't
want to dwell on it because I want to go
oh no I I you know it's a wonderful
question I don't know but I think the
case is getting more and more
interesting uh we've just discovered
that Pluto is a lot more intricate than
we expected
uh there's there's uh a lot of ice and
the ice is active there are volcanoes
ice volcanoes on Pluto indicating that
perhaps under the ice there is an ocean
and you know having water is is
certainly very helpful for uh formation
of life so perhaps there's some
primitive life on Pluto I I think it's
absolutely fascinating oh it is
yeah I I I really don't know I mean I
guess my you know philosophically uh our
human egos tend to encourage us to Think
We're Alone
uh and that makes us feel very important
but uh on the other hand the people that
believe in alien life feel like they're
uh not not unimportant but that aliens
would would want to visit us uh just the
same but but also that yeah there's a
privileged about uh us and that uh on
the one hand on the other hand we
shouldn't take ourselves uh so seriously
because life is teeming throughout the
Galaxy even though there's no evidence
anyway I don't want to distract no no
you know we'll solve the origin of Life
another time my friend yeah you know
actually it brings me on to something
else I I'll come back to this but it's a
very important Point how does life fit
into the cosmos and I have a slide about
that which won't answer the question of
whether there is maybe we'll do a part
two Neil because actually you brought up
so much interesting stuff and I know
your your time is limited and I want to
uh complete but the other thing I want
to talk about is where does
forgive me if this is loony sounding but
Consciousness in the wheelarian sense of
it from this in the Universal how does
it fit into the anti-universe Paradigm
but I I don't want to talk about that
now because I I really want you to keep
going with what you're just talking
about you later this summer and I also
want to read your book yourself
I'd be I'd be happy to do that uh in
fact I was lucky enough to work at
Princeton when wheeler was uh retired
and John Wheeler used to come uh to all
the physics department colloquia but he
wasn't allowed to drive at that point
because he was too old and so I used to
drive him home wow and so John Wheeler I
had a very young daughter at the time
who was I think two or three and I
brought John Wheeler home and
um so uh I was trying to explain to her
who John Wheeler was
Freeman Dyson when he met my father oh
yeah
over dinner here
these were incredible people and I think
uh one of the joys of being in
theoretical physics is to spend some
time with them so I said job in the
world Neil not just theoretical physics
but but also to be a scientist exposed
as you've been exposed on every concept
depth Antarctica and and your work uh
you know South Africa where I have yet
to I've lectured on all six continents
except for Africa I hope they go there
somewhere but that you've met so many
interesting people you've been involved
with young people with um science in
Africa and uh the anti-apartheid
movement I'd love to talk to you about
that so let's do a part two uh but later
this summer no that's fine let's keep
going with the with your uh anything
else you want to talk about but uh but I
know you have to go at about 15 20
minutes I gotta go babysit myself no
problem I just want to tell you one
thing about wheeler so he
I said um my daughter says to me you
know who who's John Wheeler and I said
oh he's the person who believes that
there are wormholes in the sky
and so my daughter's answer was oh
everybody knows that's wrong
wormholes are in the ground
[Laughter]
in that black hole the word black hole
and he also invented the word Wormhole
and he was the first to think about such
a kind of mind-boggling effects which
people like me are trying to now kind of
implement mathematically and and see if
those ideas hold water
but uh yeah amazing person so
um yeah I want to come to this
explanation for flatness
um we have an explanation for the
flatness of the universe which exactly
parallels this explanation for the
flatness of the Earth
um it's not atoms that you need to count
it's how many possible
states are there
for the entire material that makes up
the universe okay it's because if you
like gravitational atoms so imagine
you're building a space-time out of
something
how many of those atoms are there okay
and what I claim is that if there are
many and by many I only mean let's say a
thousand times more than we already know
about because we already have seen you
know a vast
region of the universe so if there are
only a thousand times more than what
we've ever seen well I should say
precisely I mean that the entropy is a
thousand times more than what we've
already seen
um then
um then the most probable universe is
flat that's all it takes wow just as
more atoms of the universe in the Earth
make it flatter
more degrees of freedom we say
technically in dealing with gravity make
it flatter so this is my audience that
may not be familiar the uh astonishing
thing in in Neil's famous you know kind
of lingo about the curvature of the
universe that's flat wherein there are
an infinite number of real numbers that
could be corresponding to the curvature
being positive of the universe being a
spherical positive curvature identically
there's an infinite number of negative
curvature universes where the curvature
is negative but there's only one you
know zero is a very exactly and uh and
to explain it requires either an
astonishing coincidence or a mechanism
and what Neil's describing here is a
mechanism forcing the universe no other
choice to be flat exactly exactly right
in the same sense as the Earth is
locally flat
that in a small neighborhood of the
earth you see something locally flat I
mean this work has convinced me that by
the way I have to say that our
calculations assume that the universe is
finite not infinite it can be positively
curved it can be negatively curved it
can be an arbitrary size but it has to
be finite to even
talk about the number of states you have
to assume it's finite and the result of
this calculation convinces me
whereas I didn't take the possibility
seriously before it convinces me that
the Universe could very well be finite
after all
um certainly if it's positively curved
it would be a sphere
a finite radius but if it's negatively
curved it can also be finite it requires
various Arrangements like mirrors in it
to make it finite uh and such a universe
providing it's larger than you know the
region we see the most probable States
will be flat so just show a little graph
there's a graph from our new new paper
it's about the gravitational entropy of
the universe
and so Hawking I won't describe the
graph in detail just to say it exists
it's a mathematically precise
calculation the only assumptions of
gravity and quantum mechanics and
Hawking's way of calculating entropy and
personally I think Hawking would have
loved this calculation
now what happened is so people people
before us studied
the Lambda Universe the empty Universe
which only has dark energy
that's what they could do mathematically
and they call that the sitter space the
set of space-time it's an empty Universe
apart from the dark energy right and and
mathematically it's rather easy to
handle and you can calculate its entropy
so there was this desitter entropy
and then various people asked well what
happens if I add some stuff inside this
dark energy Universe like matter
radiation what happens to the entropy
and what they discovered is it goes down
okay you the more stuff you put in it
the smaller the entropy gets and
eventually it hits zero and the reason
it hits zero is that
um it's possible to have a static
Universe you see the dark energy is
repulsive drives the universe apart as
you add more and more radiation the
radiation is gravitationally attractive
and you can balance the two to make a
static universe and and in fact this is
Einstein's static Universe model that
has zero entropy in in gravity
um and and technically the reason for
that is it has no Horizons it's just a
static space it has no entropy that's
not the universe we live in in fact
none of the universes I've just
described are the ones we live in we
live in a universe which has more
radiation than the Einstein static
universe
which came out of a big bang which is
dominated by radiation
so we succeeded recently in extending
this calculation of gravitational
entropy into the realistic regime where
you've got lots of radiation and that
radiation dominates you know decider
space is is like a sort of hyperboloid
it bounces as you go back in the past it
bounces and re-expands
um
the universe we live in didn't do that
there was so much radiation that it just
collapsed into as you go back in time it
collapses into a big bang singularity
so um sorry their dogs barking don't
like singularities
we succeeded in doing this calculation
for a realistic Universe including lots
of radiation
and when we do that we find that you see
one
is the magic number if the gravitational
entropy equals the sitter
entropy so we know what the dark energy
is today and so we know what the
corresponding entropy is of a decita
universe if our universe has more than a
thousand times the entropy of that the
sitter universe then it it turns and
because entropy goes like volume it
essentially means it's 10 times bigger
than what we see the radius has to be 10
times bigger than what we see then it
turns out that the curvature the most
probable Universe has curvature nearly
zero and that's what the blue line on
this curve shows so I I claim that
you know this calculation of
gravitational entropy indicates
that the vastly most probable universe
is actually spatially flat
um if that if this is the case then all
of us have been on the wrong track for
the last 40 years
and uh uh in fact you know a very simple
uh explanation along the same lines of
why the Earth is flat was staring Us in
the face it's due to gravity and how
gravity is reconciled with
thermodynamics and also it would
reconcile this great puzzle that was at
least brought to my attention by Sir
Roger Penrose of why the entropy was so
low in the early universe and and yeah
there's your family there's this famous
diagram yeah you want to explain
yeah let me let me tell you a little bit
about Roger Penrose Roger Penrose is uh
absolutely inspiring figure in the field
of gravity
uh he's the one who
um discovered the mathematical
properties of black holes
and who inspired Hawking
um to do the same for cosmology and
prove that uh
classically the universe began in a big
bang Singularity so Roger Benner is just
a legend he's also one of the nicest
people you could meet
he's a four-time guest on this podcast
so I know I know he features that very
it's the top of his CV there's you know
Nobel Prize
right so yeah Roger interviewed me for a
PhD place and I unfortunately only did
physics as an undergrad I didn't do
mathematics and so he interviewed me in
Oxford and he said um he kind of looked
down his nose at me and said um
what what what problem do you want to
work on I mean you're just a bloody
physicist you don't know anything about
mathematics
and so I I rather
um
arrogantly or forthrightly said what's
the hardest problem in the in the
subject and he said oh it's describing
massive particles and so I said oh great
that's what I want to work on and he
sort of looked at me like I've worked on
this for 20 years and haven't gotten
anywhere so who the hell are you so he
didn't he didn't offer me a place but
actually it was a good thing because the
problems he was working on were actually
very very hard and wouldn't be good for
a PhD student anyway but he's an amazing
person he's a very outspoken critic of
inflation
and his argument is is shown in this
picture he he draws the most beautiful
pictures too of mathematical ideas and
and also just uh his father was an
artist his father was a great artist oh
I didn't know that aha didn't know that
so uh well he his many talents
um and so this shows the puzzling
logical geometry of the universe so
you know Einstein's theory as you said
allows space to be curved and wiggled
and and to take any shape
um and uh and yet it doesn't you know
the geometry of the Universe on large
scales today
is just what people taught in ancient
Greece you know Euclid taught uh
geometry the axioms of geometry and
three-dimensional geometry you've got X
Y and Z and it's exactly what you learn
in Primary School uh that is the
geometry of space in the universe why
well what a mystery I mean why did we
need Einstein if the universe you know
chose this ridiculously ridiculous
euclidean geometry such a trivial and
simple thing with no curvature or
anything so Roger puts it in this
beautiful picture he has the Creator uh
you know deciding to start the universe
in this ridiculously special geometry
um which doesn't need Einstein at all to
understand
um why is the universe so peculiar
um and so
Penrose made the argument that if you
cut if you do the calculation of
thermodynamics Allah Hawking you again
used Hawking's idea of gravitational
entropy he guesstimated you know what
the what was the probability of a
universe so so special and flat uh as
ours
um now the what he had done in in that
guesstimate is not say anything about
the Big Bang
okay basically his argument that was
that the most probable Universe would be
a giant black hole which just contained
everything that we see uh and yes he got
used hulking's formula for the black
hole and he basically argued on General
grounds why didn't the universe just
form form a giant black hole that has so
many possible states such high entropy
that's what it would be but we're
clearly not living in a black hole
so that was his Paradox what we've done
is we actually
Implement very precise mathematical
condition at the Big Bang this perfect
mirror as I said it's this reflecting
boundary condition at the big bang that
we see ourselves in a sense through the
big bang and we implemented that and
then we used that to calculate the
entropy and it turns out that our
reflection symmetry the CPT symmetry is
what excludes there being a one huge
black hole that doesn't satisfy this
reflection symmetry and um could you
have multiple like his prime or his
error bonds or his uh Hawking points
could you have multiple black tiny black
holes or is it precluding black holes in
general from Permian this this boundary
condition precludes any black holes at
the Big Bang there's a mathematical
statement that it's what's called a
conformal zero the Big Bang is a
conformal zero it means that spaces
shrunk to a point
and the size if you like of the universe
the scale factor
um has a zero which is analytic and that
means mathematically nice so the scale
factor shrinks to zero but the geometry
which the scale factor is multiplying is
uh what we call regular namely it
doesn't have any
um divergences
at the Big Bang itself and that alone
that alone is enough to rule out big
bang it'll rule out black holes at the
Big Bang
so the black holes that formed formed
later they formed subsequently and and
for that reason there are no very big
black holes because you know they formed
uh from sort of small sizes upwards uh
our initial condition excludes there
being a big black hole and and then when
we calculate the gravitational entropy
we're not calculating the entry of a big
big black hole we're calculating other
eight other Cosmos and so
um so yeah it's interesting I gave a
talk to Roger recently and halfway
through the talk he said oh but you're
not talking about a cyclic Universe
anymore no
and and I said no I'm not
um what I'm doing is actually
implementing your old ideas from the
1970s and 80s because he had this idea
called the vile curvature hypothesis
which is basically what I just said this
conformal zero he was trying to explain
why the cosmos was simple he didn't
explain why it was flat but he was
trying to explain why it it wasn't
crazier in in the Big Bang and he made
this hypothesis I said no I'm
implementing your old idea
um which you know you gave up on some
time ago and he switched to cyclic yes
okay but now I'm switching to his uh
previous idea
and um we'll see yeah very interesting
yeah we'll have that's the luxury of
theorists
we can switch sides and uh you know
Hawking did according to Sir Roger
um
so Neil we're coming up on two hours now
uh I'd love to indulge your uh
forbearance to ask you uh three
questions that I ask all my guests uh
and then I would like to further solicit
for Barons and ask you to come back on
the show uh fourth with after uh I
digest your your second book or your uh
the book uh I haven't yet read of yours
so would you would you feel comfortable
uh answering my existential questions
courtesy okay great the first question
uh these are my so-called thrilling
three questions uh but the first one has
to do with your own personal Horizon so
if you want to stop sharing the screen
we'll take off
or actually I can I can shrink sir Roger
to a to a conference okay I shrunk him
to a singularity anyway
um
so the very first question I like to ask
involves your legacy uh both uh both
ideologically and and sort of wisdom and
that has to do with this concept of and
what's called an ethical will
[Music]
uh what what sorts of wisdom not
monetary not Material uh bequeathment
would you like to leave the world with
when you spring forth the Mortal coil as
The Bard said at age 120 in the biblical
tradition what wisdom one piece of
wisdom would you would you like to leave
the the universe with
gosh that's a tough question
um
yeah I I think
it's an appreciation and this is what I
like to share with everyone it's an
appreciate it's a feeling I've had it's
just a feeling which I've had ever since
I was a child
that
um
that the universe is is just
extraordinary
and our appreciation of it
uh gives us more riches than anything
else and and that's the wisdom that
actually the wisdom is in nature that's
my guiding guiding philosophy I think uh
nature keeps us you know
um
keeps us on the right path and and
but so take what the recent discoveries
right the universe has turned out to be
surprisingly simple
uh the Higgs was found nothing else was
found no Multiverse in the sky all right
it's Simplicity itself
and
are we able to learn from that I
literally feel that the universe is our
guide
that's the role it plays for humankind
and it has if you think about it when
people you know in in the Stone Age
you know look up at the sky and they
thought well you know that's amazing and
so it lifts you beyond yourself
it has an unimaginable sort of beauty
grandeur
that comes from symmetry it's not chaos
right the universe is the furthest thing
you can imagine from chaos that's in a
sense why and and this matters not a
single thing scientifically but this is
why I don't really like the idea of uh a
chaotic Multiverse
you know I can see why some people find
it appealing
but for me it's the opposite uh that the
universe is a guide
it's uh it's it it shows us I mean I
think about the history of physics you
know how did Newton Law learn the laws
of motion it wasn't on Earth it was by
watching the planet by taking data from
the planets he didn't he did the easy
work he just did the math
other people took the observation so you
know time and again and again and
likewise with Maxwell you know Maxwell
always gave credit to Faraday Faraday
discovered the laws of electricity and
magnetism uh plus some other people but
Faraday probably most coherently
experimental and experimentally and
Maxwell just had to write down the math
which described those laws and Maxwell
gave all the credit to Faraday now what
he was doing is not so much being kind
to experimentalist he was saying nature
tells us how it works we just have to
listen
okay and that is the job of a theorist
to listen and I don't the the criticism
I have of my own field and my own
earlier work
is we weren't listening you know we were
so full of ourselves we said oh we'll
come along and introduce an extra
Dimension and brains and all kinds of uh
phenomenal imaginary phenomena
you know but and to be fair to us we
didn't have that much data you know now
we have tons of data and it's all going
in this direction of extreme Simplicity
and economy and so I think any theorist
worth their salt should be forced now to
reconsider and say you know maybe my
model was just too complicated
very good very good okay so the next
question on my topic now goes uh maybe
further into the future Sir Arthur Clark
said any sufficiently advanced
technology is indistinguishable from
Magic in his movie 2001 A Space Odyssey
we see these apes and they they come
upon this monolith and we don't know
what it is it could be a time capsule it
could be a uh it could be a warning who
knows it could be some technology some
magical technology uh I want to ask you
kind of you know taking off from where
Feynman said uh the most the most um
most important information filled
statement in the fewest words is the
so-called Atomic hypothesis I want to
ask you if you could update Feynman or
give your own spin on Feynman what kind
of magical statement could we use to
brag about what physicist or Humanity
has learned it could be human it could
be something not related to your job but
what contains the most information that
human beings should rightfully put into
a billion year long time capsule and let
aliens know how proud We were of it some
billion years hence
[Music]
so we haven't yet it
but I think
um I honestly feel that reconciling
quantum mechanics with gravity
will will be that something the reason
why it it's so interesting and it
actually relates to particles going
backwards in time because particles what
are particles after all we think they
are what we call World lines you know a
world line tells you where a particle is
in space and time but if you think you
take the big picture and just look at
kind of all of space and all of time
what's a particle well it's just a curve
in space time
and that immediately is telling you that
geometry
is somehow gets reconciled with quantum
mechanics so quantum mechanics is making
things spread everywhere
explore everything that's all these
phases I was talking about you know the
quantum mechanics is incredibly
exploratory and indefinite
geometry is the opposite it's extremely
definite I know exactly where the
particle is at every moment of time so
these are opposites
and when we try to link gravity to
Quantum Mechanics we've got to
understand how these things reconciled
uh I think they can be it's
extraordinarily difficult when it is
uh we will we will truly be sort of
uniting opposites quantum mechanics
there's the uncertainty principle so if
you say where something is now or what
geometry does the universe have now
inevitably there's something you know
nothing about which is in the case of
the University how fast is it expanding
you know if I know exactly what the
geometry is now then I cannot know
anything about how fast it's expanding
according to Quantum Mechanics so the
only way to know anything is you say
well I know approximately this and
approximately that
um so you can see there's a huge tension
between even the notion of geometry and
uh the notion of Quant and the
uncertainty principle in quantum
mechanics so
that I think is we've got so many Clues
you see this is not Pie in the Sky we
know how particles work we know what
they do in colliders we know Quantum
field Theory Works to very high
Precision what we don't yet have is a
sort of geometrical picture of exactly
what the particles are doing and what
that even means during one of these
processes and if we gain such a
understanding mathematical understanding
precise understanding
we're going to have to do the same thing
for the universe and our place in the
universe wow um so so yeah even though
quantum gravity may sound uh very Arcane
and um you know just the kind of last uh
the dot of the eye in theoretical
physics it isn't it's much more than
that it's actually understanding the
whole thing it's reconciling these two
opposites
um and that makes it you know very very
challenging but
I think if we do succeed in reconciling
these opposites you know that will be
the crowning achievement of of physics
wow great okay third question
um I'm actually gonna ask you four again
you've been so generous I I hope you'll
continue and won't slam shot the laptop
on me but the third uh statement of Sir
Arthur was when a distinguished but
elderly scientist I'm not calling either
one of us elderly but when it's
distinguished but elderly scientist says
something is possible they're most
certainly right when they say something
is impossible they are very probably
wrong I want to ask you Neil have you
changed your mind on anything recently
uh have you been wrong about anything
[Music]
foreign
I've been wrong multiple times and I
think it's been very good for me
um I was
um I've always been a skeptic about
inflation it always looked to me too
many too many artificial ingredients in
the models but so what I did I'm trying
to be constructive is to develop
alternative
mechanisms which would explain structure
in the universe so I worked on what
seemed to be a very appealing idea at
the time which was based on Grand
unified theories
which is an attempt to go beyond the
standard model that is now kind of
fallen out of fashion
and these theories predicted
as structures called Cosmic defects
cosmic strings
and I what fascinated me about that idea
is it it was very predictive
it explained that there were these
objects swishing around in the early
Universe explained how they formed out
of fundamental physics and then they
switched around and they stirred up the
matter and that would end up making
galaxies so it was a very principled and
very predictive Theory
and I decided to you know devote uh more
time than I should have to working out
all of its predictions which I did and
then the experiments came along and they
proved me and the theory utterly wrong
um and yes it was disappointing uh I
think for about six months afterwards I
felt oh God I wish it had been right but
um but actually with hindsight it was a
really good thing that happened to me
because it made me uh even more of a
natural skeptic that and even more I
believe that a theorist job
is to come up with testable
you know precise ideas which challenge
experimentalists to go after them and
ideally to try to prove them wrong right
right your theory only succeeds to the
extent the experimenters have failed so
far to prove you wrong and uh so a
theorist job is really a provocateur I
mean that's what we should be and if our
ideas are any good at all they serve a
purpose of getting people to test them
against nature and um so yeah I I I have
been proven wrong I think it was great
that I have uh I really pity other
theorists who work on Frameworks and
paradigms which are not provable wrong
because they're just condemned to spend
the rest of their days recycling the
same old ideas and never really knowing
if they're true right my uh one of my
mentors a theoretician named Alexander
pulmonary you probably remember the name
I know him yes yeah and he is a Queen
Mary uh at College he used to say
zeldovic would tell him when he was
doing something trite or repetitive he
said and I guess it's more poetic in
Russian but he would say you are like
somebody who eats food someone else has
already eaten which uh that wasn't my
favorite my favorite zeldovic quote was
uh when I would try to do too much Alex
would say zeldovic would tell you nine
women cannot have baby in one month uh
so that was it all right last question
for you today Neil you've been so
generous so gracious speaking of
impossible Sir Arthur C Clarke's third
law says the only way of discovering
discovering the limits of the possible
is to venture a little way past them
into the impossible that's the origin of
the podcast name as I am the associate
director of the Arthur C Clarke Center
for human imagination at UC San Diego
um among other things that I'm involved
with but accordingly I want to ask you
what mysterious aspect of life it
doesn't have to be science of Life
perplexed you as a 20 year old a 30 year
old and what advice would you give to
that young man to give him the courage
to do as you've done to go into the
impossible
[Music]
right uh I think and it may sound
strange from a physicist but I think the
most fascinating thing in the universe
is life
um and the way it's organized
uh when I was young in my
um
uh late teens uh undergraduates I wanted
to go into biology and do mathematical
biology and understand what is the law
that governs life that tells you that
life will emerge
um we still are none the wiser I mean
but it's still the most fascinating
question so I I think what I I think
what seems impossible now
is to make a predictive theory of life
uh now maybe even predictions aren't the
right language for dealing with life but
somehow to gain an insight into what
life is
um i s you know we know kind of the
constraints life operates under
um but we don't have any idea of
we have some glimpses maybe of how
decisions are made
um but but you know there's a very sort
of fundamental I've talked about entropy
you know life violates the the this
second law of physics which is never
going to change that uh only things that
happen are ones which increase energy
and life sort of violates that by using
energy to deliberate to to actively
um counteract the growth of it uh of
entropy and to build ordered structures
and so I think it's absolutely uh this
day this dilemma
uh of what's driving life
you know and where is it taking it and
can we understand that in any way
um I think that that's the impossible so
just as an example I have an
undergraduate with me who in Edinburgh
came to me um
six months ago and he's been reading all
kinds of crazy uh books he's actually
doing engineering physics but he read
David Deutsch's book on something about
impossibility I I
um
yeah something like that it's an
absolutely beautiful book which I highly
recommend and um and we've been
discovered discussing you know
the general question of the emergence of
complexity in the universe the universe
is extremely simple on small scales
right there's the Higgs and their laws
of particle physics and that's it no
evidence for anything else and then on
large scales utterly simple too but in
between it's this horrible complicated
mess and if we think in a bigger picture
where are we going where is AI going to
go
where is humankind going to travel into
space explore the universe change the
universe you know so there's this
enormous scope for complexity in the
middle
while there's extreme simplicity at both
ends of the spectrum
why
uh or how do you attempt to model a
system like that which is complicate
complex in the middle and extremely
simple at the two ends small scales and
very large scales and uh anyway so he's
uh he's an undergrad and you know if and
I am telling him uh I'm encouraging him
to approach these impossibly difficult
questions I'm honest with him you know
your chances of actually making progress
are tiny
um but it's incredible fun
as it is and this has been incredible
fun for me and I hope we will be able to
do a part two Neil this has been so
great we're talking with Neil Turok I've
known and been inspired by for decades
now
um he's still so young and exuberant I
can't believe you're an Emeritus
professor of perimeter institutes the
least director there but you're now the
inaugural Higgs Professor chair at the
University of Edinburgh Neil it's been
such a delight I I thank you for staying
up late or into the afternoon I thank
your dog for being very well behaved and
I hope we welcome a part two where we
can get into Consciousness the brain
origin of life and um and a little bit
maybe of commentary on your friends sir
Roger Penrose Anna Aegis Paul steinhardt
on their bouncing models and and Contra
distinction with your uh CPT and very
for now I want to thank you and bid you
a good night thanks for the lovely
questions thanks a lot thank you
[Music]
thank you